прошу класного компоту рамкою
жителям квіти батькам добри ну війни з
брата вантажники поглядом добра денних
низьким на носінні джейн ремонт це але
великий на більше не треба так ви вирішила
пісковський у маді
нібито last ворона кирико місяців кому з
трьох простіше на сільська рада писки ук
і просила ж районної та обласної про
стане 2 тетра kill реальністю он і
стала лише зараз реформа
децентралізація якого в Україні
ж сир і продовжуєш чебурека громада
створіть асв бюджет і вирішуючи куди ви
стирчать і кішки був їх ж проектант ще
буде до гудова, але спортивні зали
едальні класники моделі ви завантажили
класних кімнат для ночами реформа
децентралізації передача страви рівня в
мадам і своїх бачили після ти я кисаме
його вирішувати знижки за лиж і ти захопив
кілька шкіл де мало вчинив може завгодно
ти одну наполегливо упи скіфських паперу dm g
500 дітей
школи будуть тільки рушили про той гай
нація
доступних уроку бюджет у модель, що збив
цех чот ти трояндою вузьких і тут заглушать
йому c не менше 60 або сотні подарунки
успішно Січ не
2017 мінімальний бюджет у нас будуть
складу ти на 14 мільйонів на кінетику
ми плануємо випий на 18 мільйонів
нам дається тілу
втече і фінансово не я нашого присвіти
метта матиас вид унаги жердини особистого
часу тому тут хоче на теренах ресурсу
на в цій
айпі дихає і зарплат його світячи нам
разом цілих школах цех середньому 2000
гривень така штука яскраво прибиральницею в
школі прибиральницями закони любить побачили
нам тут треба святий і дати
місяць і рідше ти летиш хоче батчат
результати щоб школу ремонту вали
щоб
не давали баки і простіше гори вважаю що
бар почав
вище ніс витя низькі реформи громаді
потрібно на менше тридцятим і не
гривень ps4 рук їжу допомагати вона
соціальними інвестиціями уряд путін
доводьте самим все оплачувати та
письменницькому рому року ж розруха в і
на своїх головне багатство навколо 3
ставиш лист це озеро те, що хоче
створи ти курорт цієї приносять їм і став
ейб рибу так